das hier ist eine pute genauso wie das
dass hier das und dass die meisten von
uns kennen sie aber eher so als
putenbrust als schnitzel putenstreifen
in salat oder als geschnetzeltes beim
putenfleisch haben viele von uns ein
gutes gefühl es hat ein gutes image und
ein gesundes image irgendwie besser als
hähnchen dass es in der
geflügelindustrie nicht gerade
zimperlich zugeht ist den meisten von
uns aber aus klar die meisten puten
leben er so sie haben wenig platz und
soll möglichst schnell viel fleisch
bringen
es sind krass gezüchtete hochleistungs
tiere einen mast guter weg nach fünf
monaten etwa 24 kilo
es ist eine fleischindustrie und keine
freiland romantik wir haben überzüchtete
tiere erschaffen die so schwer sind dass
sie probleme mit den beinen und den
hüften bekommen und wir sind sogar in
der absurden situation dass sie sich
nicht mehr natürlich fortpflanzen können
wenn ich da so einen großen hahn habe
von 25 kilo und der steigt auch somit
henne von zehn kilo ist die hände danach
zwar bestiegen worden aber eventuell
nicht mehr am leben
also das sind das läuft über künstliche
besamung da ist dieses natürliche moment
ist er einfach ganz raus das ist putins
richterin christine bremer und das ist
eins der dinge die sie ändern will
[Musik]
ich werde heute weniger über die
allgemeinen bekannten problemen der
massentierhaltung sprechen wir alle
kennen die bilder und die überschriften
es geht heute viel mehr darum was es
gerade bei puten so schwierig macht und
warum die öko haltung nicht so einfach
möglich ist dafür schauen wir uns zuerst
an wie sich bio und konventionelle
haltung unterscheiden was genau die
probleme in der ökohaltung sind und
welche ideen es gibt das zu ändern dafür
hätte ich euch super gerne mit zum hof
und christine bremer genommen
wegen corona ist es leider nicht
wirklich möglich und deswegen haben wir
uns über facetime verabredet außerdem
eine kollegin von mir vor ort in
niedersachsen
was mich überrascht hat für die
putenhaltung gibt es keine rechtlich
bindenden gesetzlichen vorschriften es
gibt nur eine freiwillige vereinbarung
und wenn man die online-sucht passiert
manchmal sogar das was klar ist bier
puten geht es an einigen stellen besser
als konventionell boten sie haben zum
einen mehr platz ihre schnäbel dürfen
nicht gekürzt werden und sie brauchen
auslauf im freigelände das gibt's bei
den konventionellen puppen auch deshalb
nicht weil das infektionsrisiko draußen
höher ist sie bekommen nur futter und
kein kraftfutter aber auch die
ökobetriebe meisten meistens turbo
puppen und das führt zu problemen in die
puten rassen die es gibt die wurden so
krass zu fleischproduzenten gezüchtet
das ist schwierig ist sie in der
biolandwirtschaft richtig zu füttern
die im ökolandbau einzusetzen das ist so
man kauft sich im ferrari
und dann sagt man diesel die größten
probleme liegen tatsächlich in der
aufzucht und nicht so sehr in der mast
wenn so ein tier erst mal acht wochen
alt ist dann ist das ziemlich robust
aber in der aufzucht phase füttern wir
sie eigentlich nicht bedarfsgerecht das
bundesprogramm für ökolandbau stellt
deshalb in einer studie in frage ob die
konventionellen puten hybride in der
ökohaltung überhaupt sinn machen und
2013 forderte der bnd sogar noch einen
stopp der puten sucht seither hat sich
zwar einiges verändert aber
eine sache würde die damals
verantwortliche immer noch so sagen die
hochleistungs linien in der potenz hoch
tragen oftmals das tierleid schon in
sich daher kann auch die beste bio
haltung die fehlsteuerung und den hohen
antibiotika bedarf denn durch die zucht
entsteht nicht vollständig kompensieren
ja das ist ein weiterer teil der
kritisiert wird dann durch die zucht
sind die tiere weniger robust und
anfälliger für krankheiten was natürlich
auch damit zusammenhängt dass sie in
großen ställen zusammenleben
laut monitoring bericht der
bundesregierung wird gerade in der
putenmast viel antibiotikum eingesetzt
von 2014 bis 2017 ist die menge bei den
puten nur um vier prozent gesunken es
sind immer noch 36 7 tonnen antibiotika
auch in der ökohaltung werden
antibiotika eingesetzt wenn auch
bedeutend weniger als in der
konventionellen machst was hältst du von
diesem radikalen vorschuss so mit einem
verbot zur arbeit
also es hat sich ja auch seitdem echt
einiges getan
die ganzen statistiken was antibiotika
gaben und so weiter und so fort angeht
es geht das geht ja auch zurück ist
entwickelt sich auch zurück und ich
glaube da arbeiten schon auch alle öko
puten halter und mäster und auch züchter
und vermag daran da mehr qualität und
sowas reinzubringen das ist für alle
wichtig und ich würde mal sagen also ich
finde auf keinen fall auf die pute
verzichten wollen das sehr
zum einen ein sehr lustiges tier und zum
anderen auch echt ein sehr leckeres tier
und bringt einfach auch vielfalt rein
und ist eine herausforderung dass es
keine frage
große spezialisierte öko betriebe
bekommen das mittlerweile mit dem
füttern und so weiter ganz gut hin sie
setzen immer mehr auf langsam wachsende
rassen wie die dunkle bronze pute oder
sie müssten nur henn der tour geboten
weil die langsamer zunehmen aber auch
bei langsam wachsenden tieren gibt es
probleme sie kämpfen auch mit der
überzüchtung
eine doktorarbeit der uni kassel kommt
zu dem ergebnis dass auch beim
ökolandbau keine der langsam wachsenden
rasse uneingeschränkt in ordnung ist 20
bis 30 prozent der tiere leiden auch
darunter beim fehlstellungen einfach
weil sie so schwer sind das schwierige
daran ist natürlich dass wir vor
ungefähr 70 jahren aufgehört haben die
pute als landwirtschaftliches nutztier
in ärgerlichen zucht überhaupt zu halten
die route ist schon so lange raus aus
einer bäuerlichen fleischerzeugung zucht
dass sie deshalb ein gehören aber als
wunderschöner hobby vogel gehalten wurde
weltweit beherrschen aktuell zwei große
konzerne den kompletten puppen zucht
markt das heißt die bestimmen wie groß
die tiere werden und wie sie schmecken
in deutschland hat eine rasse eines
herstellers die bio tees 6 einen
marktanteil von 90 prozent
eine echte öko rasse gibt es bisher
nicht möglich und das ist das problem
es gibt zwar 2000 trasse booten in
deutschland aber die sterben so langsam
aus weil sich die haltung als nutzt hier
eigentlich nicht lohnt wenn wir so eine
henne die wunderhübsch ist schlachten
handel wunderschöne federn haben am ende
in großen berkhout und großen berg
knochen und ganz wenig fleisch sie ist
aber rumgelaufen sie hat viel gefressen
hat lange gebraucht um überhaupt das
gewicht zu erlangen
und ich habe keinen verkaufsfähige
produkt als landwirt bei einer rassen
henne die fünf kilo wie bleibt am ende
etwa ein kilo fleisch
zum vergleich die bronze pute die schon
langsamer wächst liegt er vor 18 kilo
wenn sie geschlachtet wird und ein turbo
nas putter wiegt am ende 22 kilo davon
sind über fünf kilo brust filet in dem
forschungsprojekt von christine werden
jetzt zwei rassen miteinander gekreuzt
die robusten rassen aus der hobby zucht
mit dem fleisch booten aus der industrie
um dann das beste von beiden seiten zu
erhalten
unser gemeinsames ziel ist es
putenhaltung in kleinbäuerliche
strukturen zurück zu bringen indem wir
robuste tiere erzeugen die überhaupt für
eine kleinbäuerliche nicht
spezialisierte struktur zu managen sind
in deutschland gibt es so was gar nicht
nur sehr wenige bauern haben also die
direktvermarktung und als verbraucher
haben wir bisher kaum eine chance
herauszufinden welches tier denn in der
verpackung steckt man sieht es den puten
ja auch nicht mehr an
ob es eine turbo pute war oder eine
langsam wachsende aber wir verbraucher
haben am ende auch dafür gesorgt dass es
überhaupt so weit gekommen ist der
preisdruck auf die bauern ist nämlich
enorm
aber es gibt ganz viele kunden die
würden gerne den bauern ihres vertrauens
auch so eine pute abkaufen und diese
möglichkeit soll eigentlich geschaffen
werden dass ein ganz normaler landwirt
einfach so eine kleine puten herde
halten kann schlachten kann verkaufen
kann
und natürlich war das mal so dass man
das so gemacht hat aber die zeiten sind
einfach zu weit
mit dem modellversuch könnte sie also im
besten fall ein bisschen die zeit
zurückdrehen zu einer robusten rasse den
gebieten raus aus den nassen stellen und
zurück auf die höfe bringt die sich für
die landwirte lohnt und die nebenbei das
sexleben der tiere rettet ob das gelingt
bleibt abzuwarten
christina geht es dabei aber noch um
viel mehr für sie ist auch ein
hoffnungsschimmer für kleine höfe in
einer kleinstrukturierten haltung steht
immer ein kleines strukturierte
bäuerlicher betrieb das sind die
betriebe die alle aussterben
wie sieht's denn dann hier aus hat den
höfen und böse als leichen in der
landschaft liegen kein kein leben mehr
mit federvieh und schafen und kühen wo
wo die kinder daran teilhaben können so
ist es aktuell bei den puten ja schon
gegessen haben sie schon viele aber wer
von euch hat schon mal eine pute gesehen
es gibt hilfe und züchter und bauern den
sehr viel am tier wohl gelegen ist und
die aus den ganzen umständen versuchen
das beste rauszuholen und mit sehr viel
bewusstsein mit den tieren arbeiten aber
die muss man eben er
da finden
[Musik]
wenn ihr euch weniger für puten aber für
antibiotikaresistenzen in
massentierhaltung interessiert dann gibt
es hier noch einen richtig guten beitrag
wenn ihr mehr sehen wollt dann freue ich
mich wenn ihr hier unten in unserer
playlist vorbeischaut